the year is 1837 the streets of London
are cramped and overcrowded disease and
sickness runs rampant as both human and
vermin fight for the space just to exist
the sky is covered by thick layers of
small the air is hard to breathe and
everywhere you turn there are new
factories being built filled with new
machinery to drive us forward into this
new Victorian era an era that will
improve the lives of everyone both rich
and poor but such a transformation does
not come without a cost if you somehow
manage to survive the long hours
hazardous work environments and polluted
air there are tales of something else
to be wary of something that clamors
from rooftop to rooftop under the cover
of darkness those unfortunate enough to
have seen him describe a man who can
leap across buildings and over walls a
monster with metal claws glowing red
eyes and the ability to breathe fire
some called him the devil but even the
devil has a name and in this case that
name is spring-heeled jack
[Music]
[Music]
the Industrial Revolution marks one of
the biggest changes in British and
modern world history processes that were
once done by hand were now done by
machine the rise of a mechanized factory
system along with water and steam power
led to Britain becoming the world's
leading commercial nation in the 18th
century this however changed the entire
landscape of the country the population
had more than tripled railroads and
steam-powered locomotives now connected
the country like never before allowing
more and more people to flock to these
industrialized cities in search of a
better life
this created new larger communities that
consisted of people from all over the
country when you bring so many new
people together with a different set of
beliefs experiences and superstitions
you end up with new stories new
traditions and new tales of folklore one
of the most recognized stories to emerge
from this Victorian era is the tale of
spring-heeled Jack the terror of London
there is some debate as to when this
mysterious figure first appeared
unofficially the first alleged encounter
occurred in October 1837 the account
comes from a servant girl named Mary
Stevens
[Music]
[Music]
one evening on her way home after
visiting her parents Mary passed through
a park known as Clapham Common located
in South London all of a sudden a
shadowy figure let town of a dark alley
and grabbed hold of Mary he tore her
clothing with his metal claws and began
to touch her exposed flesh she described
his touch as cold and clammy similar to
that of a corpse as he began to kiss her
face she screamed out for help
the attacker soon fled the scene as the
locals came to examine the commotion
they searched the park in the
surrounding streets for hours but the
man in question was nowhere to be found
and Mary's claims could never be
substantiated the very next day a
similar figure was reported once again
near the home of Mary Stevens but this
time there was a new victim the shadowy
figure left out in front of an oncoming
carriage causing the driver to swerve
and lose control resulting in him
crashing and being severely injured
those who claimed to have witnessed the
event say they saw the man escape by
jumping over a nine-foot wall laughing
and babbling to himself as he fled the
scene less than four months after the
first sightings the Lord Mayor of London
officially recognized a complaint letter
in January of 1838 regarding this
unnamed troublemaker the letter came
from a resident of Peckham and warned of
a man visiting villages near London
dressed in several different disguises
it describes him as going from door to
door preying on women when no men were
home this concerned resident also stated
that it was rather strange the
newspapers had ignored these stories and
that it may have been because they were
coerced into silence to cover up these
strange occurrences as expected the
mayor remained fairly skeptical but
members of this meeting confirmed that
servant girls from kensington hammer
Smith and other boroughs situated around
London also told stories of this demon
the next day as a crowds gathered
demanding to know what was going on the
mayor showed them a stack of letters
from all around London claiming similar
vile pranks had taken place now unsure
what to make from these varying accounts
he ordered the police to search for a
man in bare skin hoping that the reward
offered would be enough to catch whoever
was responsible these stories spread
quickly and both the media and the
people needed a name for this individual
some say the first name given was steel
jack which referred to his claws and
armoured attire but the name more
commonly used was spring he would Jack
he quickly became associated with
jumping out in front of carriages and
attacking women just as described in the
first two stories it didn't take long
before Jack became an urban legend the
leaping boogey man who could be anywhere
at any time nobody was safe at a time
when many simply couldn't read or write
oral storytelling still played a large
part and the simplicity of spring-heeled
Jack's story only made him more
terrifying there were very few
backstories offered and his motivations
were unknown children were told not to
misbehave otherwise Jack would leap into
their window and take them away there is
a part of many of us that just loves a
good scare and what could be scarier
than a monster that could be waiting
around every corner hiding in every dark
crevice the original Victorian
jump-scare if you were lucky enough to
be able to read Jack made numerous
appearances in the penny dreadful for
those unfamiliar the penny dreadful were
short stories that often featured works
of horror or the supernatural which were
published every week and only cost a
penny hence the name the price and short
nature of these stories meant they could
easily be produced in mass helping
spread this popular culture and capture
the imaginations of the youth
less than three weeks after the Mayor of
London acknowledged these stories the
19th and 28th of February saw the two
highest profile encounters with good old
Jack the Otto case and the scales case
Jane also gave one of the most harrowing
accounts of spring-heeled Jack's a date
on the night of February 19th 1838 Jane
answered the door of her father's house
she was greeted by a man dressed as a
police officer instructed her to bring a
light and follow him as they had just
gone Spring Hill Jack near Bonnie
Jane did as she was instructed and
followed the man outside with a candle
however when she handed him the light he
threw his cloak to the ground and
revealed himself
Jane described it as a most hideous and
frightful appearance his eyes resembled
balls of fire and he was vomiting white
and blue flames from his mouth he also
wore a large helmet and his clothing was
tight-fitting which Jane described as
resembling white oil skin or skin being
a waterproof garment commonly worn by
sailors and fishermen
Jane shocked by the man's appearance
stood there powerlessly as he grabbed
hold of her and began to tear her gown
with his metallic claws after a brief
tussle she was able to break free and
make her way back to the house screaming
for help along the way before reaching
the steps of her front door the man once
again grabbed a hold of her this time
chlorine and tearing at her arms and
neck one of her sisters hearing the
screams came to Jane's rescue and the
man fled upon seeing her a few weeks
after this attack a man by the name of
Thomas Milbank came forward claiming
that he was in fact spring-heeled Jack
in a local pub the man was never
convicted because Jane was adamant her
attacker could breathe fire and to no
one's surprise mr. Milbank was pretty
clear that he could do no such thing
it's quite difficult to take Thomas
Milbank's confessions seriously because
if he wasn't crazy or seeking Fame he
did confess in a pub most likely whilst
very intoxicated
just nine days after the attack on Jane
or Saab a Miss Lucy scales and her
sister were walking home one evening
when they came across a man dressed in a
cloak in a dark alley when passing by
the man turned to Lucy opening his mouth
and unleashing a violent spurt of blue
flames into her face losing her sight
she fell to the ground and woke up later
in her home where she would continue to
have violent fits as a result of the
attack it was Lucy's brother who had
heard his sister screams just after they
left his home when he arrived in the
alley he saw his sister holding Lucy
down as she violently convulsed when
describing this attacker to the police
both miss scales and her sister
described him as tall thin and
gentlemanlike unlike the case of Jane
also the man said nothing and never
tried to lay his hands on her he also
never escaped by jumping over any walls
or fences he merely walked away despite
several rounds of questioning and
numerous suspects the man was never
apprehended after these alleged
encounters spring-heeled jack appeared
in countless newspapers and had
established himself as one of the most
prominent figures of folklore from the
Victorian era the question everyone had
on their mind was who or what was this
mysterious man or entity he became a
popular figure for the penny dreadful
and his story spread quickly he could
even be seen in more common Street
Theatre becoming a substitute for the
devil in Punch and Judy shows now trying
to nail down Jack's appearance with so
many conflicting accounts isn't easy
the earliest accounts described him as a
shadowy ghost it's likely Jack himself
emerge from the ghost stories of the
early 19th century even in his final
sightings which ventured outside of
London two cities further north such as
Sheffield and Liverpool he was referred
to as a ghost just before the end of the
19th century
you also have accounts that say he was a
man dressed in bearskin along with the
popular notion that he was in fact the
devil another popular description that
later emerged is that of a cloaked
gentleman dressed rather oddly
whether that was in a skin-tight wetsuit
metallic armor or even just the fancy
dress that looks like a weird Victorian
Batman who you certainly wouldn't want
around children is up to you with all
the history around the legend of
spring-heeled Jack
there were many skeptics who tried to
explain how this story may have started
one explanation given is that of a crazy
man who used to run across rooftops
claiming he was being chased by the
devil laughing to himself and spouting
incoherent nonsense others thought Jack
was more than just one man and the
entire thing was an elaborate prank
although the people who described their
encounters didn't sound like they were
having a fun time the journalist Peter
Haining wrote a piece about Jack
possibly being an irish nobleman by the
name of Lord Henry Beresford he believed
the Lord's drunken disorderly behavior
coupled with his previous negative
experiences with women were the main
reasons they were his primary victims
this however remained an unsubstantiated
rumor I think the most reasonable
explanation comes back to every period
of time needing some kind of boogeyman
and Springhill Jack was a manifestation
of the fears many felt during the
Industrial Revolution it was a time of
rapid change and uncertainty we see this
in Jack's mysterious nature no one truly
knows what he looks like and there is
always the constant fear of not knowing
if you were next his metal claws
represented the rise of mechanized
factories and his fire-breathing mouth
mirrored the everburn in furnaces it's
also not a stretch to say Jack may have
represented some of the fears that women
felt during this period those who came
from small quaint villages may have had
quite the culture shock in the bustling
streets of London especially in those
more unsavory areas where the treatment
of women was even worse
like many tales of folklore and fiction
sometimes they're created to allow us to
escape reality as dark as it may seem
may be tales of a shadowy gentleman with
metal claws and the furnace mouth who
could leap across buildings and avoid
the authorities were just less awful
than the reality of working in a factory
under terrible conditions
maybe that sense of mystery fantasy and
fear offered some excitement at a time
which would have been quite bleak from
anyone who wasn't part of the ruling
class he may not have been a real
monster or ghost but maybe spring-heeled
Jack was the boogeyman the Victorians
needed either way it makes for an
interesting story let me know what you
think if you have enjoyed this video and
you'd like to see me continue making
content with animations original
soundtracks and artwork then you can
support the channel over on patreon for
as little as one dollar a month
regardless of how much you choose to
pledge every patron will have the chance
to vote on future topics and have their
name mentioned at the end of each video
it is a goal of mine to be more active
and patreon this year as it seems to be
one of the only ways to keep the channel
going so if you would like to see behind
the scenes updates for god in artwork
and animation and future videos you can
do that on patreon I don't want to fill
my videos of mid-roll ads and
sponsorships and I really really don't
want to make another raid shadow Legends
promo so if you'd like to save me from
that any support is greatly appreciated
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explained